c'est marrant des fois je rêve que je
suis milliardaire et que je suis obligé
d'aller vivre en belgique ça c'est pas
une position avant j'ai dit si vous êtes
milliardaire il ya d'autres endroits que
la belgique way plus ensoleillés ainsi
elle - - bas mais c'est sympa la
belgique mais si je peux vous convier
aller faire un petit tour sur la grand
place selon en belgique
ça va ses fans mais ça va super bien
manger quoi là des flics moi je mange
des frites whisky et on nous a dit de
nous la belge qu'il fallait manger cinq
fruits et légumes par jour
donc l'homme le belge mange des frites
c'est quand même bizarre un pays dont
dans la statue la plus connue c'est un
petit garçon qui fait pipi dans l'eau à
ce moment on sait les américains ils ont
pas mis une femme comme ça à très grand
très belle je tiens une torche qui
éclaire le monde et tout et vous à un
môme qui puise en quoi
c'est ça la vraie liberté à eux ils ont
la statue
nous on a la stature je suis bon
le belge n'est pas fier c'est pour ça
qu'il avait dit
cinq ans
de vie choisir de lille dans un seul
lieu toute votre vie vous choisiriez la
france ou la belgique
ça mérite un petit coup de bière ouais
[Musique]
très bon la bière chaude
et les free froid vous avez essayé
faut inverser dès de mettre les fruits
dans la bière chaude
c'est pas moi c'est un territoire entre
les deux qui s'appelle red à frangy qu
à part le mc cain pile de trucs à voir
en belgique et la jeune pis à 1 femme
qui s'accroupit pour faire pipi ah ouais
comme la mode econ peas et sait où ça
c'est pas loin de la grand-place c'est
la lépi soit hier donc il est le petit
garçon
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'en belgique on peut visiter la
maison de philippe geluck
si vous n'êtes pas chien avec lui je
pense qu'il vous fera visiter sa maison
est-ce qu'on peut visiter à d'amour et
comme tous les monuments oui
j'ai connu le temps aux ou bruxelles
bruce les a mais vous me parlez de la
bresle gicl mais bruxelles chante
toujours bouge cette danse et on danse
la belgique a
il est allongé le fric là je veux dire
le belge aime tellement les frites qui a
annexé une partie de la frite
g2 le club
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus